and also on top of it awesome really
wants to do a podcast with you yeah
would you do her podcast sure does she
have a podcast yeah she's an amazing
podcast yeah let me listen I I don't
know I I'm not in the podcast where I
don't know if there's no podcast world
it's like I want to do a podcast I think
you would be great I'd crush a [ __ ]
pot it's all so easy easy to do I know I
want to do with my sister too
oh my god it would have been amazing
guess Lapita right it would be top
[ __ ] floor tea right no I love this
[ __ ] though I love just talking and
bullshitting about so it's fun it is
it's fun and let me tell now I'm gonna
say this that it really like like I was
just in El Paso and ninety percent of
the crowd our Tiger belly fans they were
the shirts I also do think that
podcasting I think that information is
disseminated that way now I think that
it's a newer form of media I think that
people find it more relatable yes more
casual it's more chill and when people
guests come on this podcast people feel
like okay I know I'm better versus the
other yeah you know we've had great well
I mean you with that Vanderbeek yeah
although Hanson I feel comfortable that
yeah yeah blacks Jordan Peele who's your
boo the biggest star you've had on there
Jordan Jordan Peele Stonestreet Eric
Stonestreet that's cool
how was he he's funny great he's good
dude I love him yeah but you know these
are people that I have a relationship
yeah yeah yeah I don't yeah well you
have you read anyone you don't know now
you're know I don't think that we would
ever have somebody that he wasn't yeah
at least you know familiar with yeah
yeah I mean I doesn't feel right right
you coming into our home so it's yeah I
feel yeah this is my house and also on
top of it it has to be I have to feel
comfortable about it because if I don't
we've had YouTube
stars that would that are kind of you
know family yeah we'd their family their
family but I don't know them that well
where I thought Google them a little bit
you got to do a little research a little
research but you know the I'm still they
still are excited to be here because I'm
above them yeah but if if it's anyone
that's above me and I don't know them I
wouldn't be able to do it right because
then I don't know where I can go yeah
yeah me I need the power
would you let Barack Obama say well I
mean not that he would do it but Marc
Maron he did Marc Maron's right in DTF
and of course I would have to but I
wouldn't mean it Trump come I know you
wouldn't your [ __ ] mind but just to
do the pot Trump says he would podcast
yeah we'll take Trump says Bobby I want
to come to your podcast you would say no
what what yeah I think we would have to
say yes
now we're crazy I'm crazy not really
high jacket and railroad everything you
say but it would still be fun yeah I
think that'd be fun and if his
presidential personal note doesn't come
out like I want him to be the slumlord
Trump like the old-school Howard Stern
yeah yeah yeah because what would happen
though is is that like his PR people
would come in here or forever yeah and
go these are the things you can't talk
about Sarah Huckabee just standing it
that would be good get you should get
Sarah huh I mean like I just because I
just I mean I mean I was just in El Paso
and I won't name names but I ran into a
couple of guys they're a huge Trump you
know and I bit my tongue
mmm-hmm you know they say some [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] you bout your tongue but at
the at the end of the day there is a
division mm-hmm there is a difference
between me and them and they meeting I
may never be able to like find a bridge
you know it's so divided to me that I I
can't we don't even talk about on this
podcast because now it's so volatile oh
yeah
you know people go crazy yeah well I
don't talk that's like in my Instagram
stuff I'd never talk right but I know
how you feel
well I'm told me I'm not I'm not I'm
independent you know and I mean I know
you feel you told me ninety-nine
thousand a week give Oliver Hudson round
of applause he was [ __ ] amazing you're
amazing thank you guys you add
information so much fun you took improv
clouds you added information there were
no space and I try not that I don't feel
good
what was it almost like Notting Hill is
an hour 30 Oh mom no Rob calm yeah
that's you know why it's a mirror that
didn't feel you know what was a miracle
because at 50 minutes I always go what
do we had time ass and I never and
that's why he was gonna keep going yeah
no but no with you is this like natural
well that's how we know it's fun yeah I
mean friends for life friends for life
let the show gets canceled
[Music]